con 19 votos a favor nueve en contra y
una abstención la comisión permanente
del Congreso de Perú aprobó acusar
constitucionalmente al expresidente
Pedro Castillo por los presuntos delitos
de organización criminal tráfico de
influencias y colusión por la
manipulación de licitaciones para la
construcción de un puente compra de
biodiesel e irregularidades en el
Ministerio de vivienda junto al ex
mandatario también se aprobó procesar a
los exministros Juan Silva y heiner
Alvarado conforme al procedimiento del
parlamento peruano se programará una
nueva sesión en la que una subcomisión
sustentará la acusación ante el pleno
del congreso para la votación final por
otro lado hoy la presidenta Dina
boluarte en una conferencia de prensa
formuló un llamado al parlamento para
que retome el debate de adelanto de
elecciones llamo a los congresistas y a
la comisión de Constitución Son ellos
los que tienen que resolver dijo la
mandataria boluarte también reconoció
que la democracia en Perú es la más
frágil de latinoamérica la jefa de
estado realizó un balance de los dos
meses de gestión de su gobierno advirtió
que hay grupos violentos que amenazan al
país y señaló que las fuerzas armadas ya
están en regiones como puno para imponer
el orden y el principio de autoridad